[Music]
this year's Oscar nominees took their
annual class photo how cool is that see
Kobe Bryant right down in front
Carly Steele is with me how to talk
about a peach me moment for one of those
folks there I would say that's
especially true for Best Supporting
Actress nominee Allison Janney who
unlike her character and I Tanya opted
to come without a certain feathered
friends I personally wish the bird had
made an appearance in the Oscar photo I
brought him out at the globe so maybe
that's enough you don't think he'll be
making an appearance at the Oscars it
really was my bird and he would hang out
on my shoulder it would be fun to go
down the red carpet with that we'll see
you never know okay
no bird but Alison was kind of
photobombed by this cardboard cutout of
a French filmmaker who couldn't make it
but sort of stole the big day even the
queen of all things Oscar Meryl Streep
was impressed whenever I'm in a room
with Meryl Streep you know that's that's
a good day she's the queen this is like
summer camp for her she's over here with
Margot Robbie in this chic Chanel mini
dress Saoirse Ronan and orange cutouts
the Oscar nominee luncheon is getting us
pumped for a knockout Oscar red carpet
do you know what you're wearing Oscar
day I just saw some sketches today I
don't want to say anything but it's
pretty hot yeah yeah I've had a couple
of but bang feelings from a dresses I
feel like I'm gonna be in an episode of
say yes to the dress but one thing you
won't see are repeat of this okay I love
it you've gone barefoot have to just
took the shoes off had to Julie Roberts
citizencon
so you're like the Julia Roberts of the
Oscar nominee luncheon going fairly I
think of myself yeah
[Music]